that fight Smith the partially blocked
with defense by Smith Jr who was second
team all-rookie last season's and thanks
home of three Doris Brown I didn't hear
him called it but yeah Babs will take it
think about how explosive he is an
athlete and Vince Carter hits nothing
but net entire career with the Los
Angeles Clippers there's that stick back
three-pointer Doris and Glen's signed a
one-year deal after playing his first
couple years with the Phoenix Suns who
drafted him initially why that is a
smooth move by Thompson with the ball
back for the Mavs who were in the midst
of an 11-3 run and trying to increasing
his looka taken away by Trey young he
has had a lot of opportunities on
drive-bys three on the way and Luca Don
Cheech is on fire here folks in Atlanta
release on the way by Matthews is off
the mark and four game Brits from the
corner got it he's got to be able to
make those open shots but young hasn't
scored he hasn't scored a field goal
until now
[Applause]
extra pastor Don shits on the drive got
it - Paul Overland was in between great
patience
Dallas has only got one rep in a
possession ballgame
[Applause]
[Music]
nonsense six of 17 on the even gets that
layup to fall young